[Musique]
le deuxième son il fait ça
maintenant je vais vous demander de
regarder ces deux images
je vais vous poser une question selon
vous laquelle parmi ces deux images
représente mieux le premier son que vous
avez entendu je vous le refais
alors selon vous est-ce que c'est
l'image de gauche ou plutôt l'image de
droite cette image là on est d'accord
qu'est-ce que ça nous dit
et bien ça nous dit que le processus
d'écoute d'un son en fait il est assez
complexe en plus d'entendre les
propriétés physiques du son la durée
l'intensité la hauteur et bien on va
associer au son qu'on entend une idée un
concept et cette idée ce concept en fait
il est lié au Gest sonore qui est
produit lorsque l'on créé le son et ça
il y a un chercheur qui a théorisé ça il
s'appelle Denis Mallet et lui il dit que
dans le cas d'une écoute acousmatique et
bien notre écoute est conditionnée par
notre connaissance du geste
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire je sais vous
avez rien compris mais on va reprendre
les termes les uns après les autres
tout d'abord une écoute à cosmétique
qu'est-ce que c'est une écoute
acoustique c'est le cas où vous entendez
un son mais vous ne voyez pas la source
par exemple si là sur cette scène je
mets un piano ici que je prends un
rideau que je tends que je mets ici
entre vous et piano et bien vous depuis
le public ce que vous allez voir c'est
un rideau on est d'accord
et maintenant si je demande un pianiste
de venir derrière ce rideau pour venir
jouer du piano et bien vous serez dans
le cas d'une écoute acoustique vous
entendrez le son mais vous ne percevrez
pas la source ou pardon l'inverse vous
percevrez la source mais vous ne verrez
pas le son
et bien dans ce cas là votre écoute est
conditionnée par votre connaissance du
geste bah oui le piano tout le monde
sait ce que c'est vous avez déjà vu un
piano vous avez déjà entendu le son d'un
piano je suis sûr qu'il y en a même
certains ici qui ont déjà joué du piano
et bien tout ça toute cette section
toute cette expérience va venir
conditionner votre écoute maintenant si
derrière ce rideau je le retire le piano
je le mets là bas et je prends un
instrument que vous avez jamais vu vous
connaissez pas le son qui fait et le son
qui fait vous n'arrivez même pas à
identifier un son qui ressemble à ça
dans la nature
et bien votre écoute elle sera quand
même conditionnée par votre connaissance
du geste sauf que là le geste vous le
connaissez pas qu'est-ce que vous allez
vous faire vous allez l'inventer
et ça c'est quand même assez incroyable
et là vous vous dites
pourquoi je vous parle de tout ça c'est
vrai finalement quel est le but de cette
présentation et quelle est la direction
que j'ai envie de lui donner
et bien en fait je vous parle de tout ça
parce que je suis passionné par les
enregistrements mais vraiment depuis que
je suis tout petit déjà les vinyles de
mes parents je trouvais ça fascinant les
pochettes des vinyles c'était incroyable
je voyais ça je me disais mais comment
ils ont pensé des idées comme ça quoi
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment fou et du
coup quand j'ai retiré les vinyles et
que je les ai posé sur des platines et
que j'ai entendu qu'en plus il y avait
du son qui allait avec la pochette
c'était le feu je m'imaginais les
pochettes s'animer je voyais Michael
Jackson danser enfin c'était incroyable
c'était fascinant et puis après j'ai
découvert l'ordinateur j'ai découvert
surtout l'ordinateur de ma grand-mère
qui était un iMac à l'époque et sur
cette IMA qui avait GarageBand et
GarageBand franchement je sais pas si on
a certains qui connaissent mais le
concept il est incroyable l'idée c'est
qu'on a accès à une base de données
d'enregistrement vraiment incroyable de
très bonne qualité et que ces
enregistrements peut les prendre pour
créer d'autres enregistrements en fait
on prend des enregistrements pour faire
des compositions et ça pour moi c'était
vraiment incroyable j'ai saigné garage
boom franchement ma grand-mère elle se
servait pas mon ordinateur de son
ordinateur et bah moi je m'en suis servi
à sa place deux fois plus
c'était trop bien
et puis bah après j'ai eu l'argent j'ai
pu m'acheter un ordinateur et j'ai pu
acheter une carte son et du coup j'ai pu
enregistrer ce que je voulais donc là
j'étais super content j'enregistrais ma
mère qui faisait du piano mon petit
frère qui faisait de la contrebasse mes
amis qui rappaient mes amis qui
chantaient j'ai même enregistré des sons
sous l'eau mais là c'est une autre
logistique il faut un hydrophophone
c'est un microphone qui va sous l'eau il
faut plus de câbles il faut des bateaux
c'est une autre organisation
et même il y a pas très longtemps de ça
j'ai pu enregistrer quelque chose
d'assez facilement assez incroyable
c'est le cœur de ma fille dans le ventre
de sa mère et ça vraiment c'était une
expérience qui m'a subjugué bref je suis
passionné par ça je suis passionné par
les enregistrements d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui je suis rappeur j'enregistre
ma voix je suis vite Maker j'utilise des
enregistrements qui existent déjà pour
faire mes compositions et je suis
chercheur je cherche des nouvelles
façons d'utiliser les enregistrements
pour la musique
petite question de culture générale
est-ce que vous savez par qui et en
quelle année a été inventé le premier
système capable d'enregistrer un son
non
souvent quand je pose cette question les
gens savent pas et il y en a
quelques-uns qui savent et qui me disent
Thomas Edison 1877 le phonographe et
bien en fait non le premier système
capable d'enregistrer un son il a été
inventé par un Français et il s'appelle
Edward Léon Scott de Martinville et lui
en 1857 il a inventé un outil qui
permettait d'enregistrer un son mais pas
de le restituer vous pouvez enregistrer
mais vous pouvez pas écouter ce qu'on
avait enregistré c'était quand même
assez frustrant il a fallu attendre 2008
pour que des une équipe de recherche
américaine elle met au point une
technique pour entendre ce qu'il y avait
sur ces enregistrements parce que sa
machine elle permettait de dessiner sur
une feuille de papier long acoustique
sauf qu'en 1857 bah on n'avait pas la
technique pour entendre le son depuis
ses dessins
du coup cette équipe de recherche elle a
pu entendre pour la première fois le
premier enregistrement de l'histoire de
l'humanité et vous saviez ce que c'était
vous savez ce que c'est oui
exactement c'est Édouard lion Scott de
Martinville seul tout dans son atelier
qui chante au clair de la lune et ça
franchement c'est incroyable bref nous
on va laisser l'invention de Édouard de
Martinville de côté et on va revenir sur
celle de Thomas Edison parce que c'est
cette invention qui a révolutionné le
Game bah oui imaginez-vous vous pouvez
enregistrer un son à un endroit à un
instant T et vous pouvez le restituer un
autre endroit à un autre instant vous
imaginez si vous êtes un artiste en 1900
et quelques la portée que ça en terme
d'expression
d'ailleurs c'est pas forcément les
musiciens les premiers à voir pensé
utiliser l'enregistrement pour faire de
la musique pour faire de la création
artistique pardon par exemple le poète
Apollinaire en 1914 lui il s'imagine que
avec le phonographe on pourrait le
mettre à plusieurs endroits dans une
salle et restituer
en même temps plusieurs poèmes
ensuite il y a eu le compositeur Carol
Berard en 1929 lui il s'imagine que en
enregistrant plein de son et en les
assemblant les uns à côté des autres on
pourrait obtenir de nouvelles symphonies
et puis 20 ans après c'est l'invention
du GRM par Pierre Schaeffer le GRM en
fait c'est un groupe de recherche qui
réunit des chercheurs des chercheuses
des compositrices des compositeurs des
ingénieurs qui vont qui vont réfléchir à
de nouvelles formes d'expression
musicale utilisant notamment
l'enregistrement ils en vendent des
machines un peu chelou comme par exemple
le phonogène à bande qui en fait un
instrument de musique à part entière qui
est constitué d'un magnétophone et d'un
clavier de piano et en gros le clavier
de panneau bah ça permet de régler la
vitesse du magnétophone du coup quand je
vais taper dans les touches plutôt
graves ça va dire lentement
l'enregistrement et quand je vais taper
dans les touches plutôt aiguë je vais le
lire rapidement
vous voyez il y a vraiment plein de
façons d'utiliser l'enregistrement puis
aujourd'hui on utilise plus trop ces
systèmes parce qu'ils sont analogiques
et qu'aujourd'hui on a inventé le
numérique on utilise plutôt des
sampleseurs par exemple je suis sûr que
vous voyez ce que c'est c'est une sorte
de petite boîte sur lequel il y a des
pads des touches et quand on va appuyer
sur une touche on va déclencher la
lecture de l'enregistrement un endroit
dans l'enregistrement et comme ça on a
plusieurs touches comme ça on peut aller
à plein d'endroits différents dans
l'enregistrement en appuyant sur les
touches il y a un musicien qui s'appelle
fakir je suis sûr que vous avez déjà
tous vu ce qui fait en live il a
toujours cette petite boîte là comme ça
qui souvent s'illumine il appuie sur ses
touches et en fait là ce qui fait c'est
qu'il déclenche la lecture
d'enregistrement tout simplement
il y a aussi des compositeurs beaucoup
plus extrêmes par exemple John Oswald
lui il est un peu barré en fait il prend
un enregistrement et il se dit je vais
faire une musique que avec cet
enregistrement par exemple il a pris
l'enregistrement de Michael Jackson bad
et il a créé une œuvre qui s'appelle dab
et franchement c'est très chelou il a
pris que ce qu'il y avait dans Michael
Jackson il a récupéré plein plein de
segments et il a refait une œuvre
complètement différente à partir de ces
segments là
vraiment il y a plein de façons de se
servir des enregistrements et moi il y
en a une en particulier qui m'intéresse
beaucoup je lui ai donné un nom
et cette façon là c'est animé la musique
sur support en fait ce terme-là il
désigne le fait d'interagir musicalement
avec le déroulement d'un enregistrement
bah oui aujourd'hui si on veut écouter
un enregistrement qu'est-ce qu'on fait
on s'assoit dans le métro on appuie sur
play et puis on attend tout simplement
que sur Spotify la musique se joue dans
nos écouteurs alors qu'en fait il y a
plein de façons fun de le faire par
exemple je pourrais appuyer sur play et
puis battre une mesure et en fonction de
la mesure que je suis en train de battre
et ben l'enregistrement pourrait être le
plus vite ou moins vite si je m'arrête
l'enregistrement bah il pourrait
s'arrêter ou la note elle pourrait durer
moi c'est ce genre d'interaction qui
m'intéresse
et pour pouvoir y réfléchir j'ai
développé un logiciel
et ce logiciel il s'appelle mono Replay
et pour que vous puissiez voir un peu
presque peut faire ce logiciel je vous
ai préparé une petite vidéo qui va
illustrer une
[Musique]
donc vous voyez il y a vraiment plein de
façons d'utiliser les enregistrements
et sur cette vidéo je sais pas si on a
certains qu'on reconnut l'enregistrement
que je suis en train de jouer
c'est le piano pour pour corder le trio
pardon pour corde et piano numéro 2 de
Franz Schubert opus 100 et ce que
j'utilise comme instrument que vous
voyez là sur le sur le bac dans la vidéo
qui était projetée avant s'appelle le
médecin instrument et en gros le temps
instrument c'est comme un super
contrôleur c'est une super grosse
manette en fait qui me permet de
récupérer plein de gestes que je vais
faire et ces gestes en fait ils vont
juste me servir à piloter le logiciel du
coup que j'ai développé
donc vous voyez en fait dans cette
présentation j'essaye de vous expliquer
à quel point l'enregistrement il a une
place particulière dans ma vie bah oui
depuis que je suis tout petit avec les
vignettes de mes parents jusqu'à
aujourd'hui dans mes activités
l'enregistrement il est vraiment au cœur
de ma vie
et en fait ça je m'en suis rendu compte
en préparant cette exposé en vérité
j'avais vachement peur de venir ici non
pas parce que j'avais peur de parler
devant vous même si ça c'est une peur en
soi mais j'avais une autre peur en plus
c'était de vous raconter quelque chose
qui était trop technique qui était un
peu trop geek qui était pas forcément
très intéressant dans le cadre d'un TDX
sachant que moi ce que j'aime bien dans
ces conférences c'est qu'on parle de
choses personnelles qu'il y ait des
espérances de vie des choses inspirantes
du coup je me suis dit comment je vais
faire j'ai pris plein de choses que
j'aime bien dans ma vie et je me suis
dit je vais essayer de parler ces
choses-là mais il faut trouver un lion
quelque chose en commun entre toutes ces
choses là
et ce lion bah c'est l'enregistrement
d'ailleurs là actuellement on est en
train de faire un enregistrement bah oui
la vidéo elle est en train d'être
enregistrée après elle sera mis sur
Youtube et vous pouvez la regarder après
chez vous
et peut-être quand la regardant bien
vous vous souviendrez vous assis dans
cette salle en train de me regarder et
moi je me souviendrai d'être debout là
et en train de vous faire ce cette
conférence parce que les enregistrements
c'est aussi ça finalement c'est des
souvenirs c'est des souvenirs qu'on crée
ensemble qu'on fige un instant T pour
rendre ça éternel et en plus c'est des
souvenirs qu'on peut partager avec les
autres
donc aujourd'hui je suis vraiment
content de vous parler de tout ça pour
moi ça a été un peu une révélation de me
rendre compte qu'en fait ma vie elle
n'était pas si bordélique que ça que
c'était centré sur une seule chose
l'enregistrement et
enfin façon de parler et du coup bah je
suis très content d'avoir partagé tout
ça avec vous et j'espère que dorénavant
lorsque vous entendrez un enregistrement
et bien vous imaginerez que derrière il
y a des musiciens qui s'en servent pour
faire de la musique il y en a même
certains qui font des gestes musicaux
pour jouer des enregistrements et que
finalement l'enregistrement c'est
peut-être un instrument de musique à
part entière merci de m'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]